[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france france 24 nuestro primer programa
de 2021 un año que esperemos traiga
esperanza al planeta y en el que veamos
el final de la pandemia sobre la que
lógicamente gira la actualidad y de
nuevo este programa se encarga de ello
porque si hay un elemento que trae
esperanza este 2021 son las vacunas y de
ese elemento vamos a hablar hoy en el
programa les presento ya a nuestros
invitados sergio linares es científico
experto en vacunas del laboratorio de
biología tisular e ingeniería
terapéutica del centro nacional de
investigaciones científicas en francia
bienvenido sergio buenos días carlos
iván sánchez periodista de radio francia
internacional de la rúbrica ciencia
bienvenida a ibón gracias por johann
cortinas muñoz sociólogo en el instituto
de ciencias políticas de parís y experto
en políticas de salud bienvenido gracias
carlos y a distancia tenemos desde
barcelona-el profesor jeffrey lázarus el
ex profesor asociado de la universidad
de barcelona y del instituto de salud
global centro impulsado por la fundación
la caixa señor lázarus buenos días
las vacunas es el gran elemento de
esperanza para 2021 hoy en primera plana
[Música]
el 2021 comienza con la esperanza de las
vacunas y el miedo al mismo tiempo
permanente casi podríamos decir a los
rebrotes aquí en europa ya arrancaron
las campañas de vacunación criticadas en
algunos países como francia por su ritmo
lento mientras otros como reino unido ya
están en su tercer confinamiento por lo
contagiosa que es esa variante británica
del virus en latinoamérica la campaña de
vacunación está marcada por la
desigualdad entre unos países y otros no
todos los países han asegurado desde
luego el mismo acceso a las vacunas
vamos a analizar cómo marcha en estas
campañas de vacunación en estos primeros
pasos pero antes repasemos algunas
portadas de la prensa en alemania
frankfurter rundschau la esperanza de la
primera dosis argentina diario litoral
la sputnik la vacuna rusa llega a 21
centros logísticos aquí en francia la
croix se hace eco de otra realidad los
países pobres tendrán que esperar pese a
las promesas titula dice el rotativo que
incluso a incluso algunos países tendrán
que esperar dos años el nuevo herald en
florida alta demanda choca con baja
capacidad en los hospitales del sur de
la flor
bueno sergio no sé podríamos decir que
las vacunas son la gran esperanza de
este 2021 que acabamos de estrenar para
mí sin duda son la gran esperanza y si
estoy seguro de que van a cambiar el
curso de la pandemia y de aquí a lo
mejor a un año las cosas serán muy
diferentes a las que estamos viendo y si
la hemos vivido en el último año bueno
en este inicio de vacunación de campañas
y con lo que estamos viendo los
diferentes ritmos hablamos de algunos
países que van muy rápido como israel
aquí en europa hay muchas críticas a
países como francia que tienen un ritmo
bastante lento quizá la pregunta es
porque si las vacunas están ahí aquí en
europa no se implementa un ritmo más
rápido en algunas bueno también o
incluso hay distintas estrategias no por
ejemplo creo que indonesia decidió
vacunar a la gente joven en cambio aquí
en francia se decidió vacunar sobre todo
primero los lugares lo sé para dónde
están las personas mayores se podría
decir que son distintos puntos de vista
porque todavía incluso no se sabe bien
este por ejemplo si las vacunas pueden
evitar los contagios o si más bien
previenen sobre casos graves no entonces
en francia quizás por distintos motivos
de organización
hay una logística recuerden que hay una
logística muy complicada sobre todo con
esta primera vacuna de arn mensajero de
la fisher que es esta que se necesita
guardar al menos 70 grados centígrados
eso ya complica bastante la logística a
nivel de almacenamiento de producción
también etcétera
luego nos va a explicar si hay muchos
factores y quizás también hay distintas
estrategias que sean que se han optado
en los países
johann que conoce muy bien las políticas
de sanidad muchas críticas aquí en
francia ese ritmo de vacunación también
en otros países como españa están
justificadas estas críticas bueno la
crítica siempre es buena y el debate
siempre es bueno lo que yo lo que me
parece importante es que si algo hemos
aprendido esta pandemia es que sabemos
pocas cosas y hablando evaluaremos cómo
ha ido si la planificación ha sido buena
o no al final del proceso ahora es como
si evaluaremos un partido de fútbol en
el minuto 2 del partido no decimos que
ha ganado tal persona no de momento no
por lo tanto paciencia distancia un poco
de tranquilidad y ya veremos al final en
verano como dice sergio
han ido las cosas de momento vamos
avanzando cada uno a su ritmo cada uno
con su estrategia y ya veremos cuál ha
sido la buena si se puede decir que hay
una buena o hay varias que pueden
considerarse como positivas en señor
jeffrey desde barcelona- entendemos que
la eficacia es la propiedad que se busca
con las vacunas pero como hay tantas y
cada una con una tecnología distinta
digamos cuál sería ese factor común que
deben cumplir todas ellas
bueno todas las vacunas tienen que
cumplir una eficacia lo más alto que sea
posible y ya con 94-95 vamos bien y lo
de más atrás de mí que con 75 también
está bien es la cuestión no sólo la
eficacia sino la esta actividad cómo van
a funcionar en el mundo verdadero
hablamos de esas vacunas de esta
tecnología de arn mensajero que es la
tecnología de las vacunas facer y de
modernas
sergio en qué consiste esta tecnología
explicado de una forma sencilla de una
forma sencilla en las vacunas de forma
general ante las anteriores están
producidas de proteínas
imagínate que esta proteína es el
producto final de cualquier fabrica una
fábrica de coches sería el coche que
produce en este caso si quieres cambiar
la fábrica puedes decir enviar todos los
planos de cómo se hacen los coches cómo
se hace la fábrica lo envías a otro país
si quieres cambiar la localización o
envías todas las piezas que es más
sencillo enviar toda la localización en
20 están enviando todas las piezas para
montar una nueva fábrica y eso es en lo
que consiste las vacunas de adn es decir
toda la información que utilizas como
fábrica las propias células del cuerpo
es decir la información y ya son
encargadas de producir estas proteínas
que al final es el producto final de
cualquier vacuna y no es sin más el adn
lo único que en vez de
producirlo fuera como se han producido
todas estas vacunas anteriormente dudas
sólo la información a las células y
ellas mismas de las zonas de tu cuerpo
son capaces de generar el producto final
de las vacunas aprobadas digamos que lo
que no conocemos el pregunto a sergio
también se quiere responder y bueno joan
la gran incógnita es la duración de la
inmunidad no
pues sí esa yo hice una presa en tu
programa sobre la rn mensajero y esa
buena pregunta
en realidad cuál es la inmunidad
entonces yo lo por lo que yo entendí
respuesta
hasta ahora los estudios todo se estudia
eficacia tienen resultados por unos dos
meses es decir esto se debe a que la el
proceso de vacuna
del desarrollo de los ensayos clínicos y
obtener los resultados en el tema de
pandemia es algo que nos ha dado tiempo
de todas formas la inmunidad es algo que
se está vigilando y se está no se puede
saber con certeza y es algo que se está
viendo en tiempo real es decir se está
evaluando por cuánto dura en la
inmunidad pero por ejemplo hay gente que
habla mucho de los anticuerpos los
anticuerpos imagínate que estamos en la
guerra y son las balas de guerra no es
el único factor que incide en la
inmunidad tenemos sobre las memoria que
incluso si bajan los anticuerpos tenemos
células de memoria que si están ahí en
el momento de que la guerra se declaren
es como soldados que no estén disparando
el momento que se declaren
son capaces de lanzar balas en este caso
también sería importante es un sistema
que se está siguiendo así que en el
futuro es algo que se está viendo por el
momento la los anticuerpos son altos se
genera una buena memoria pero es algo
que se está siguiendo día a día para ver
cuánto dura y en el caso de que decrezca
se va a volver a vacunar o se va a hacer
estudios para relanzar esa inmunidad son
los tiempos de la ciencia pero también
están los tiempos paralelos de la
política en claro encontramos ya que el
diseño de las campañas de vacunación
cuando hablamos de estos retrasos hay
una falta en la previsión en la
estrategia del diseño de estas políticas
de estas campañas de vacunación por
ejemplo aquí en francia hay una falta
que quiere decir una falta es ese no
están bien estructuradas la estrategia
de cómo se ha diseñado la campaña de
vacunación hay una política de
comunicación correcta
repito es siempre es difícil juzgar tan
rápidamente lo que sí sabemos lo que sí
hemos ido viendo porque hace casi 11
meses que estamos en esa pandemia lo
donde puede pronunciar los en tema no en
términos de comunicación es verdad que
no tiene la sensación de que nos acaban
de explicar bien las cosas es decir la
población sabemos muchas cosas pero de
voces muy distintas y nos falta un poco
de argumentos más racionales más
sosegados y que vengan de los poderes
públicos en una época donde la
credibilidad la palabra pública está muy
cuestionada no hace falta saberlo ya
hemos visto en muchos países hay un
problema de legitimidad de esa palabra y
hay que ir con mucho cuidado porque esto
está minando el proceso de
implementación y de planificación es
decir todo el mundo critica mucho habla
muchos gobiernos no saben cómo situarse
yo creo que tienen que hacer un esfuerzo
aún mayor de pedagogía de honestidad y
de transparencia y eso me parece que
falta un poquito
ivonne yo diría que también algo que
nuevos factores de que muchos países hay
por lo menos 30 países que están
haciendo campañas de vacunación entonces
permite compararnos claro entonces eso
también vamos a decir fomentar
crítica y también en francia hay una
tradición de decir bueno hay que pedir
un permiso hay todo un programa un
protocolo yo sé también que en las en
los epa hay muchísima presión por parte
del ejido muy bien
en estas residencias y ancianos la
presión viene no a veces de los mayores
sino de los familiares que están
llamando por teléfono a los directores
por favor yo no quiero que me que mi
papá o mi mamá se ha vacunado
es decir hay toda una serie de
obstáculos entre la burocracia entre los
familiares que opinan quién es el tutor
etcétera que ha complicado y por qué
porque tenían si solamente hay un millón
de dosis no creo que hay un millón de
dosis de vacunas este en francia tienen
que escoger no entonces se descorrió a
las personas mayores y en esta
estructura administrativa es complicado
entonces pero yo yo estoy de acuerdo con
jon se me hace muy prematuro para
criticar así como se está haciendo
actualmente el francia
professor lázarus barcelona algo que
usted ha estudiado muy bien y sobre lo
que ha publicado es el tema de la
inmunidad de rebaño
las personas habría que vacunar para
lograr esa unidad de rebaño en qué
momento llega a un país esta inmunidad
bueno con otras enfermedades demás
hablando de unos 70 por ciento con 19
hablamos de 75 por ciento como mínimo y
ojalá 80 85 y eso quiere decir por todas
las edades y bueno una equidad entre la
población también profesor lázaro
alargar el tiempo de para aplicar la
segunda dosis como recomiendan ciertos
expertos de la oms
es una buena estrategia retardar esa
segunda dosis para disponer más cantidad
de la primera
es una muy buena estrategia y hay una
escasez de vacunas en países donde eso
no es un problema pues no hace falta
halagar pero también es cuestión de
comunicación hay que explicar bien a la
población por qué lo están haciendo y
eso fue uno de los problemas en
inglaterra
por cierto el tema de estamos hablando
de las vacunas la rusa y la china la
desconfianza sobre la vacuna rusa la
china están fundamentadas sergio
sí y no es decir son vacunas en las
cuales tenemos menos información y los
datos no están totalmente públicos como
por ejemplo están para las vacunas que
están aprobadas en europea pero no
quiere decir que no dejen de funcionar
también hay que decir que el sistema la
calidad que tienen estas vacunas y el
sistema cómo se producen y demás no
siguen los estándares europeos es decir
tienen que seguir todos estándares y la
aprobación de la agencia europea del
medicamento para poder llegar a europa
es lo mismo que por ejemplo un coche que
se produzca en china aquí no es legal
utilizarlo muchos de los coches el coche
funciona así pero tienen todos los
estándares de seguridad toda la
aprobación y demás entonces ahí es donde
entramos también es decir funcionarían
sí pero tienen que validar y tienen que
validar todo el proceso de europa y dar
todos los datos para después ser
comercializado aquí sino momento a una
breve pausa para la vuelta les quiero
preguntar por un tema también bastante
polémico deben ser las vacunas
obligatorias enseguida en primera plana
y
[Música]
la cuenta personal de donald trump en
twitter fue suspendida permanentemente
ante el riesgo de una mayor incitación a
la violencia después de la eliminación
rompa escribió desde otra cuenta la
presidencial estadounidense desafiando a
la red social 'twitter' también le borró
estos mensajes
avanza la investigación federal tras la
muerte del policía del capitolio herido
durante los disturbios que generaron
seguidores de trump algunos
pertenecientes a grupos de extrema
derecha a favor del supremacismo blanco
del derecho a portar armas de la lucha
contra el feminismo o el
ultranacionalismo como el movimiento
cubano
el 2021 o comienza de manera crítica
para américa latina donde las cifras de
muertes y contagios por kobe 19 están en
pleno ascenso brasil superó los 8
millones de casos colombia registró más
de 18.000 contagios en 24 horas y perú
halló un caso de la nueva variante del
coronavirus
hola bienvenidos de vuelta que las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es alan
austria twitter suspendió
permanentemente la cuenta de donald
trump a raíz del ataque al capitolio la
red social ha eliminado la cuenta
personal del presidente saliente después
de esta eliminación
trump escribió desde otra cuenta la
presidencial estadounidense desafiando a
la red social y anticipando que creara
una nueva plataforma twitter argumentó
su decisión en no permitir otra
incitación a la violencia
más temprano hablamos con los rones
winner él es analista político que nos
explicó la importancia de la decisión de
twitter
bueno ese ha sido definitivamente un
evento tremendo para donald trump hay
que recordar que donald trump casi
inventó el estilo de liderar un país por
twitter ahora está suspendido él ha
dependido de esta acción y este
mecanismo para para motivar a su base
ahora va a ser mucho más complicado
complicado aún siendo pretendido eeuu
hay preocupaciones sobre la libertad de
expresión definitivamente porque el
presidente de méxico lópez obrador
mencionó eso y hay que tener cuidado
aunque yo creo que las acciones del
presidente el miércoles mostró al mundo
el peligro de mantener el control de
este mecanismo de media social los
congresistas demócratas siguen buscando
activar los mecanismos disponibles en la
constitución para que donald trump
abandone el poder
el líder demócrata en la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi advirtió que
el congreso tomará medidas y activará el
juicio político para destituirlo y
agregó que habló con un alto mando
militar para pedirle que evite que
trompa acceda a códigos nucleares entre
tampoco entretanto el presidente
saliente confirmó que no acudirá al acto
de toma de posesión de bailén rompiendo
una tradición de más de 150 años
byd en celebró la decisión de jíber de
building al menos 13 personas se
enfrentan delitos federales relacionados
con esta toma del capitolio
estadounidense el miércoles y otras 40
han sido arrestadas y acusadas en el
tribunal superior
las autoridades confirmaron el arresto
de este hombre richard barnet se tomó la
oficina de la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi y es una de
las 13 personas que enfrentan múltiples
cargos federales tras los disturbios que
se presentaron en el asalto al capitolio
de eeuu el pasado miércoles este arresto
demuestra a todas las personas
involucradas en la incursión del 6 de
enero en el capitolio de eeuu que el fbi
los encontrará y los hará responsables
de sus crímenes sin importar su
ubicación
de acuerdo con el más reciente
comunicado del departamento de justicia
a unas 40 personas han sido arrestadas y
acusadas en el tribunal superior por
delitos que incluyen entrada ilegal
violación de toques de queda y otros
relacionados con armas de fuego las
imágenes captadas durante el asalto al
congreso estadounidense juegan un papel
fundamental en las investigaciones las
autoridades examinan las fotos y vídeos
tomados por periodistas además de las
publicaciones en redes sociales para
identificar a los alborotadores que
ahora son buscados por la justicia el
fbi ofreció hasta 50 mil dólares por
información que conduzca al arresto de
una persona sospechosa de colocar bombas
caseras en washington los disturbios en
la sede del legislativo han dejado hasta
el momento 5 personas muertas entre
ellos un oficial de policía del
capitolio que resultó herido cuando
trataba de contener a los partidarios
del presidente de donald trump y una
mujer veterana de la fuerza aérea que
recibió un impacto de bala mientras
trataba de ingresar al recinto según la
policía del capitolio al menos 50 de sus
agentes resultaron heridos
en américa latina países como argentina
o méxico siguen la línea de otras
naciones de la región y anunciaron
restricciones para frenar el avance de
la pandemia nos lo cuenta juan pupiales
son días de buen clima en la argentina
el verano se siente en estas playas pero
en medio de un panorama preocupante en
lo que a la pandemia se refiere en los
últimos días los contagios diarios se
han más que duplicado en el país para
afrontar esta situación este viernes el
gobierno central restringe la movilidad
en la noche según el número de casos
registrados en los últimos 14 días los
gobernadores y gobernadoras cuando estén
en con estos riesgos epidemiológicos
deben tomar medidas relacionadas a la
restricción de circulación oa la
restricción de actividades adaptadas
naturalmente a su realidad adaptadas
naturalmente a sus costumbres y a sus
horarios
mientras tanto ciudad de méxico cuenta
con una ocupación hospitalaria del 86
por ciento este día aquí estaba previsto
que el domingo terminara el cierre de
negocios no esenciales el gobierno
capitalino anunció que esa restricción
finalmente se extiende hasta el próximo
viernes en la ciudad a un muerto 23 mil
personas a causa del hobbit 19 en un
territorio en donde en total la cifra de
fallecidos
es más de 131.000 eso los entrenamos
todos los tres hospitales hasta cuatro y
a veces hay que rezar a su casa porque
no encuentran un hospital y acaban por
decirnos a nosotros misión y buscar una
alternativa de un médico cabezazo
domicilio algún tratamiento en ese caso
al igual que europa américa latina tiene
ahora la preocupación añadida de la
nueva variante británica del cob it este
viernes perú confirmó la detección de la
rama en una persona de lema que no había
viajado al extranjero la nación inca se
une a otros países como chile o brasil
que también confirmaron la presencia de
esta variación y brasil un día después
de haber superado los 200.000 fallecidos
reveló esta placa a las afueras de río
de janeiro en honor a aquellos que se
llevó la pandemia este viernes el país
supera otro umbral más de 8 millones de
contagios
el gobierno francés confirmó que dado el
aumento de contagios cines y bares no
abrirán sus puertas como estaba previsto
a fin de mes los restaurantes son uno de
los negocios más afectados por la crisis
sanitaria
las hamburguesas son la especialidad del
restaurante caminito cabaré en el barrio
13 de parís y en tiempos de pandemia uno
de los pocos platos de su exigua carta
desde el 30 de octubre están cerrados y
sólo pueden vender para llevar
pese a ello el espíritu no decae ni
tampoco la afluencia fiel del público
es una forma de ayudar y además nosotros
tenemos que comer de todas maneras
elegimos los lugares que más nos gusten
hoy vine a tomar un examen presencial a
mis alumnos y aprovechamos para venir a
almorzar al mediodía como solíamos
hacerlo
veníamos seguido a este restaurante y es
una buena ocasión para apoyarlos en este
periodo como se practica
los restaurantes en francia estuvieron
cerrados tres meses durante el primer
confinamiento y volvieron a cerrar el 30
de octubre pasado sin perspectivas de
pronta apertura los pocos que han
sobrevivido como el cabaré caminito de
aurelian lo hacen gracias a las ayudas
públicas
hace un año que sólo luchamos por
sobrevivir pasamos el día calculando
cómo hacer para que nuestra empresa no
se hunda la captura o la venta para
llevar es cool pero no es viable
económicamente no somos un fast food
no vamos a distribuir hasta altas horas
de la noche además nuestros precios son
más altos que los de la comida rápida
para redondear sus fines de mes aurelian
y su equipo tienen un puesto miércoles y
domingo en este mercado de barrio es una
iniciativa de la municipalidad de parís
y cada día experimentan diferentes
propuestas de amor
no es fácil volverse experto en
panqueques como tampoco atravesar esta
crisis pero una buena dosis de humor
hace las cosas más fáciles y finalizamos
con las nevadas históricas en el centro
de españa el gran temporal de frío y
nieve que afecta al centro del país
considerado histórico ha provocado el
cierre de numerosas carreteras grandes
dificultades circulatorias en núcleos
urbanos como madrid y sus alrededores y
demoras y anulaciones de vuelos y
transportes ferroviarios los dejamos con
estas imágenes ya con más noticias al
momento en france 24 punto com
[Música]
siempre que hay un líder asesinado
tenemos que pensar quién se beneficia
mujeres que protagonizan la agenda
política no son sino económica social
cultural del mundo han conversado con
los periodistas de france 24 en español
no es una moda pasajera el feminismo es
una forma de ver la realidad
en primera plana esta semana hablando de
las vacunas la gran esperanza que
tenemos en este 2021 que acabamos de
comenzar y lo hacemos con ivonne sánchez
compañera periodista de refugio en
cortina es muñoz sociólogo en el
instituto de ciencias políticas de a
distancia desde barcelona- el profesor
jeffrey lázarus de la universidad
barcelona y el instituto de salud global
centro impulsado por la fundación la
caixa y sergio linares científico
experto en vacuna sergio en un tema del
que se habla mucho se habla mucho estos
días de la variante británica del virus
que es más contagiosa pero no más letal
y que ha obligado a boris johnson a
decretar un tercer confinamiento una
pregunta que tenemos todos en mente este
tipo de mutaciones varía la eficacia de
las vacunas bueno hasta el momento el
resultado que él
no se piensa que vaya a variar la
eficacia vacunas pero se hace un
seguimiento continuo de cómo puede
variar es decir en esta en esta proteína
sólo tiene 17 cambios de entre 1100
diferentes cambios que podría tener es
decir al final es como si a una persona
con gafas le quitan las gafas sigue
reconociendo a esa persona
en el futuro hay que seguir guiando y
viendo toda la información que obtenemos
porque una vez que vacunamos ahí podría
aumentar el riesgo de que cree una nueva
variante que sea inmune a las vacunas
porque porque si esa variante es capaz
de infectar a personas que están
vacunadas es más fácil que se propague
dentro de la población si toda la
población está vacunada entonces todo
eso
es importante y se está siguiendo es de
primera mano pero ya te puedo decir que
una vez que la vacuna estaba aprobada el
generar una nueva vacuna podría tardar
unas seis semanas desde cero veamos con
un tema polémico deben ser voluntarias
las vacunas deben ser obligatorias vamos
a hablar de los escépticos del tema de
la aceptación social limpieza o por
usted señor profesor lázarus barcelona
deben ser las de la vacuna del cob y
voluntaria hasta qué punto para todos
los públicos
pues no no en problemas que fomenta
operación
y siempre habrá gente que puedan evitar
la vacuna y no sabremos no sabríamos
quiénes son lo que sí se puede hacer con
prospecciones por ejemplo no va a entrar
en un país 15 vacunado o un avión y no
puede trabajar en hospitales escuelas
para pero hace lo obligatorio no osea no
obligatorio pero sí con restricciones
ivonne yo escuché que ahora en japón
están pensando en que los atletas que
participen esa era obligatorio vacunarse
entonces como que exactamente en ciertos
casos quizás se podría ser obligatorio
johann igual que el profesor la hacer
uso obligatorio me parece
contraproducente no podemos tener un
policía o un enfermero detrás de cada
persona pero sí que es verdad que habría
que hacer de nuevo pedagogía explica muy
bien porque se tiene que vacunar hasta
que el nivel de población es necesario
vacunar para evitar un riesgo de blog de
bloque de las sociedades económico
político que está sucediendo y a partir
de ahí tomar medidas
digamos indirecta es decir evidentemente
si no llegamos a los niveles
necesarios para evitar un problema de
salud pública cómo hacemos para que la
gente la incitemos a vacunarse pues se
pueden pagar los tratamientos y se
enferman se les puede obligar a eso se
les puede obligar si quieren viajar a
tener un pasaporte y tener una vacuna
medidas indirectas pero obligatorias de
un principio me parece evidentemente una
una muy mala idea pues les reformular la
pregunta empezando por joan que conoce
mucho las políticas de sanidad pública
que ya la pregunta sería qué
herramientas deben usar las autoridades
para que no falte aceptación social y
para combatir esos índices por ejemplo
que tiene francia de un 56 por ciento de
gente que dice que no piensa vacunarse
muy buena pregunta y de nuevo estamos
esos pesos sondeos son muy hábiles no se
mueven es decir ahora estamos en el
minuto uno de partido y se han movido y
estos cifras igualmente vamos a ver a
medida que avanza la campaña como la
gente va cambiando de mentalidad decir
las opiniones son muy movibles la gente
no está fijada en no quiero vacunar
menos eso avanzando a primera mucha
reticencia y luego nos vamos adaptando
no vamos a ver cómo avanza el segundo
qué medidas por lo que decía antes me
das incitativas es decir vamos a ver
cómo le hacemos para que la gente que no
se ha vacunado y qué
en peligro a la salud pública si fuera
el caso al final de la campaña cómo le
hacemos pues repito medidas indirectas
que ya se hace en otros tipos de
políticas si uno está borracho y de un
accidente de coche es su responsabilidad
no signos del seguro este tipo de cosas
no si te pones enfermo pues te vas a
pagar el tratamiento o no podrás viajar
o no podrás tendrás que ir hacer
teletrabajo cinco días por semana medias
más indirectas que van a generar más
adicción que no me diese impositiva y en
este contexto profesor lázarus barcelona
de repente surge una nueva polémica el
famoso archivo de los no vacunados en en
qué consistiría este registro de
personas que rechacen la vacuna según
dicen las autoridades sanitarias por
ejemplo las españolas se pretenden
conocer las razones de la reticencia
pero las variables y los datos que se
utilizan es decir no debe existir este
tipo de archivos señor lázaro
es una muy buena pregunta
lo que yo estoy viendo es que hay mucha
gente que tienen muchos miedos del betis
pero hoy la idea del registro de no
vacunados aunque ellos quieren vacunarse
si así que tienen miedo de que como lo
van a utilizar las autoridades porque lo
están haciendo ahora con tanta polémica
con las vacunas así que yo creo que es
una cuestión todavía abierto y lo que yo
diría es más importante tener como han
dicho el pasaporte de este vacunado
la prueba de estada speedo vacunado
desde un registro de no vacunados
bueno pues vamos a desmontar algunos
tópicos con sergio que hay en los
argumentos de los negacionistas y los
anti vacunas por hacer un poco de
de función social de aceptación social
vamos a ver
argumentos que utilizan los anti vacunas
y un usted me va respondiendo sergio
linares los efectos secundarios de las
vacunas que ya están aprobadas pero son
mayores que los de cualquier otra vacuna
pero que conocemos hasta ahora en
principio no es decir los efectos
secundarios mayores que mayores o que
tienen la vacuna normalmente es dolor
fiebre y no es mucho más que eso hay que
decir que cualquier tratamiento
cualquier enfermedad hay un riesgo
beneficio tenemos una enfermedad que
tiene una alta mortalidad una alta
incidencia muchas secuelas en pacientes
que han quedado infectados entonces el
riesgo-beneficio es innegable hay más de
15 millones de personas vacunadas y
cuando había 15 millones de personas
infectadas había miles de muertos cosa
que nos han dado con las vacunas es
decir este riesgo beneficio es lo que
vemos y es lo que tenemos que acercarnos
a qué respuesta se le da desde la
ciencia el tema de los plazos rápidos
para haberla sacado adelante que es es
lógico es de es verdad que se han
acortado muchos plazos constituyen un
riesgo para la salud pública este
recorte de plazos
estamos en una situación en particular
es decir el acortamiento de los plazos
si esperamos mucho más al final el
problema que va a haber es el tema de
que va a haber muchos más infectados y
mucho más muertos está una situación
particular estamos una pandemia se han
cortado algunas libertades y además
entonces es normal pero se ha hecho todo
lo posible para obtener todos los
resultados y la vacuna se ha mostrado
segura
hasta este punto hay que decir que está
aprobada bajo un uso de emergencia es
decir porque estamos en la situación
actual los ensayos clínicos en fase 3
continúan pero el uso el
riesgo-beneficio es claramente favorable
a la vacuna es decir al final no se ha
visto ningún efecto adverso los efectos
adversos suelen aparecer en torno a las
6 semanas después de vacunarse en los
mayores y ha sido un proceso el comité
de revisión de seguridad tuvo un dato
hasta dos meses después es decir ahí
engloba todos los efectos inmediatos más
graves que pueden generar cualquier
intervención y claramente un 95% con un
incluso con un 70 por ciento de eficacia
el beneficio de no tener como bit de
gente que está muriendo miles de
personas es algo que no nos damos cuenta
por ejemplo en tres días mueren más
personas as han dado casos que en tres
días mueren más personas que en todo un
año en a cientos de tráfico es algo que
tienes que dar números tienes que quizás
debemos hacer hincapié en esa idea no
trasladar esa idea para que la gente sea
consciente la vacuna es un instrumento
más pero quizás nos estamos equivocando
al pensar que es la panacea en este 2021
como que la pandemia va a desaparecer
porque tenemos ya la vacuna y johann
existe evidentemente es un pilar muy
importante pero como dicen los
epidemiólogos y los profesores aquí
científicos nos confirmarán seguramente
hay otros pilares que van a tener que
seguir es decir las distancias sociales
todas las medidas de prevención más
estas medidas decir no se puede dejar
una cosa ni lado las mascarillas
etcétera vamos a seguir durante un
tiempo así hasta que veamos justamente
cómo evoluciona esta epidemia y hasta
qué punto podemos ser entonces estas
vacunas van a ser muy importantes pero
vamos a ver que seguir avanzando con dos
piernas no la piel la prevención y la
vacunación es decir regresar lázarus
barcelona las vacunas no eximen de la
responsabilidad individual que tenemos
cada uno de nosotros a la hora de tener
estos gestos barrera no durante ese
estar vacunados
y hay que seguir con las medidas de
control de siempre mascarillas están ya
lavar las manos evitar grupos grandes y
es no no sólo una cuestión de
responsabilidad individual también las
autoridades tienen la responsabilidad de
ayudar a la gente a tomar estas medidas
y eso puede ser más quería es gratis as
desinfectantes gratis
y otras medidas para evitar grupos
grandes máscaras puente público etcétera
y bueno yo quisiera regresar un poco de
lo de las antiguas ruinas porque me
parece que es también muy infantil decir
poner todos en el mismo en la misma
canasta es decir todos una antivacunas
todos son envasados en teoría este
mercado no tiene por qué ser una anti
vacuna exacto puede ser simplemente yo
quiero saber cuáles son los efectos
secundarios yo quiero saber quién es el
responsable jurídicamente si a mí me
pasa algo eso todavía esas cláusulas por
ejemplo de los contratos no están muy
claras yo y quizás también de manera
egoísta yo quiero esperar un poco y que
otros se va claro quizás hay que también
tener una responsabilidad colectiva pero
yo no creo que es algo así como blanco y
negro en las personas no necesariamente
son anti vacunas son quizás prudentes y
quieren esperar
porque en muchas otras campañas de
vacunas se han dado casos que se tuvo
que ajustar la vacuna o mejorar o se
hicieron cambios entonces y además en
porcentajes tan altos yo no creo que hay
un 56 por ciento de los franceses
negacionistas serán escépticos y como
dice ivonne habrá matices no no tiene
por qué ser negro o blanco
a dudas que pueden ser razonables
simplemente prefieren esperar porque por
ejemplo si hay un caso donde se han
hablado de estos efectos secundarios de
alergias alergias muy importantes bueno
hay un dato científico que son 10 veces
no 14 veces más que la vacuna de la
gripe o sea no son cosas así imaginadas
claro es de todos modos eso es una
proporción muy mínima a las personas que
quieran pasar pero bueno yo yo soy me
gustaría ser un poco más sutil con este
movimiento anti vacunas que si
desgraciadamente es un factor en estas
en esta campaña pues así terminamos
muchísimas gracias a los cuatro ha sido
un placer yo creo que ha sido muy
ilustrativo nuestro primer programa de
año era necesario hacer un programa
sobre las vacunas y yo creo que el
panorama que hemos dado es bastante
completo muchísimas gracias joan sergio
profesor lázarus desde barcelona- ivonne
y a todos ustedes hasta la próxima
semana quien en primera plana gracias
[Música]